even in traditional conservative
heartlands party loyalists are watching
events in Westminster in horror well you
have to say if we had an election
tomorrow I wouldn't really want to go to
the count I mean the issue at the moment
is the uncertainty and the Panic really
that a lot of both industry but also
just residents are feeling at the moment
these party members in Surrey are all
very relieved that Jeremy Hunt their MP
is now Chancellor he is an immensely
able man and I've got no doubt that he
will work well with uh with Liz truss
and I think that he will work with
others I think he will understand the
market he will know what has to be done
and he will do the right thing pretty
quickly originally they all voted for
Rishi sunak to be leader should Liz
trussco they would now back MPS to
decide the new prime minister not their
fellow party members I think it's really
important to uh to listen to what MPS
are saying because they work day in day
so they know those characters perhaps
better than most of us would they aren't
calling for trust to resign just yet but
take a short trip up Downing Street the
one here in Farnham and patience is well
it's completely gone bring back forests
I reckon if they say oh they doomed and
they will label just get in butchers and
brothers Steve and Richard Lamport have
always voted conservative but they fear
what the Prime Minister will do next I
think they'll be loved but similar
places to this that are going to gonna
go under in the end if if it all carries
on as it is can't see him surviving to
be honest with you including myself for
now they won't change their vote
unconvinced another party would be any
better but the polls suggest for many
conservative voters even begrudging
loyalty has become too much to expect
Becky Cottrell Sky News Farnham